okay I'm recording let's look like good
like you and two cars back there that's
cool that's me hey guys so I am in
Madrid for the Ford Focus global test
driver let me tell you what I just did
you see these guys back there well I was
just in one of them with Justin Bell
insane let's watch this footage right
now leave me a comment below what your
favorite part was are you ready I am
just ingesting you know what we are like
related with Annie I think a little you
have an en I ever don't have it Ivan in
what I know them oops okay how would you
okay so you're very good at getting in
the car on your at Katella yes but I'm
similar to anthem it looks good I'm a
chance look big in this I think you look
good thank you much perfect no no listen
week oh yes they read all boy okay oh
gosh ok cool I think that should be me
oh my gosh i'm such a slow driver too
are you well what happens here is we're
gonna have a race with your sister oh
she's like out that corner there ah oh
gosh let's ask you i have a home with
them I'm going on you know you look good
in it can you look at your light on
clubbing with it oh gosh I don't club a
noble is it well you should just go
something holy sweet swerving celery
stick yet without saying you'll say
this is just like going sir
Bloomingdale's in there oh my god so if
a guy picks you up on a date the drove
like this what would you tell her you'd
cry I would probably cry dramtic well I
mean he students practice well yeah he
doesn't break mine oh wow one of course
now we're in our little forward we're
having whew that was crappy line they're
not no drugs being made okay up we go
the hill so do you like being driven
generally or is this not a pleasant
experience p actually not as bad as I
thought it was gonna be because I'm
pretty confident you're not gonna Rex
I'm paid not to wreck that's the whole
point of being here but I'm never too
sure with us gonna happen on okay well
don't say that city don't do I never
take it back okay here they come the big
overtaking maneuver there they go
they're just don't bacon us really yeah
oh wow whoa whoa sweet oh my gosh oh
here they are they're so close to
I'm so close I know the thing is is that
anna has done this before he's actually
quite good you know like like more than
good is like one of the best in the
world yeah I think he's half my age when
she's slightly annoying this is going to
be one of those youtube videos you make
that's gonna make people feel very sick
this is hopefully going to be going
viral prob irell videos in the Mego
spiral and maybe nausea I'm getting sick
just watching your back oh my gosh so
would you do this often do you know what
yet you come here often oh I'm Alex I
for sale in Madrid it's my first time
too really yeah but do you know what I
like about driving cars plays it
everyone is different everyone has their
personality like the focuses
personalities all like naughty and cheek
Ian so that's why we're doing this it's
pretty awesome I'm not as scared as I
thought I was gonna be that's good try
stealing your driver we just do
titillated where you titillated but
slightly fabulous there we are wow it
was better than I did was it pendant eat
it well so bad that I did better than
you did but thank you so much for
joining us my pleasure anytime as I
don't be like fifteen dollars do you
take paypal yeah okay perfect thank you
or any like my USB wow wow assistant it
no one edition we'll see we'll see